When Mike and Sara bought their house, they were in their 30s-- been renters all their lives. Not married, no kids yet, but heading there.
当Mike和Sara买下他们的房子时，他们三十多岁——这辈子一直都在租房。没结婚，还没孩子，但已经在计划了。
We had saved some money for a down payment, and we used all of that. So we had no money to furnish the house with.
我们存了一些钱作为首付，并且全部用光了。所以我们没钱给房子添置家具。
And we were two people who had been living like grad students, basically. So yeah, we moved in our futon, and we moved in our--
而且我们俩基本上一直是像研究生那样生活。所以，没错，我们搬进了我们的榻榻米沙发，还有我们的……
They had a little table that they got from Mike's dad's garage. Their chairs were these plastic stacking deck chairs-- the ones from Kmart. They had two desks. And that was about it.
他们有一张小桌子，是从Mike爸爸的车库里弄来的。他们的椅子是那种塑料的堆叠式露台椅——就是那种Kmart卖的。他们有两张书桌。差不多就这些了。
So most of the house was empty. Most of the rooms had nothing in them. And so on the weekends, they would go looking for furniture. At first, they tried yard sales. And then they learned about estate sales, barn sales. They live in Maine.
所以屋子里大部分地方都是空的。大多数房间里什么都没有。因此，每逢周末，他们就会去寻找家具。起初，他们尝试去庭院旧货出售。后来他们了解到了遗产拍卖会和谷仓拍卖会。他们住在缅因州。
The thing that they wanted more than anything was to get a dining room table. If they had a dining room table, they could have friends over for dinner, and they really wanted that. But the problem was they never had enough money to win at these barn auctions. Somebody would always outbid them. And Mike says he was seeing a side of Sara he had never seen before.
他们最想要的东西就是一张餐桌。如果他们有一张餐桌，就能邀请朋友来家里吃饭，这是他们真正想要的。但问题是，他们从来没有足够的钱在这些谷仓拍卖会上赢。总会有人出价超过他们。Mike说他看到了Sara从未展现过的一面。
She turned into an absolute different person at these barn auctions. They would hand her a paddle, and she would have to win, which is not good when you don't have any money.
在这些谷仓拍卖会上，她完全变成了另一个人。他们会递给她一个竞价牌，而她必须赢，这在没钱的时候可不是什么好事。
Yeah. You give me a paddle, and I'm not going to sit there with it on my lap the whole time. And so then I would get a little wound up.
是的。你给我一个竞价牌，我是不可能一直把它放在膝盖上坐着不动的。所以后来我会变得有点情绪激动。
After this one time when she spent hundreds of dollars that they did not have on something that looked from the back of the room where they were sitting like it was kind of a table but did not actually turn out to be a table, the two of them decided, OK, no more barn auctions. But Sara was not done.
有一次，他们在离拍卖台很远的地方坐着，她花了几百美元买了一件看起来像桌子的东西，结果却根本不是一张桌子。那次之后，他们俩决定，好吧，不再去谷仓拍卖会了。但Sara还没死心。
Well, then I discovered this little thing called eBay.
嗯，后来我发现了eBay这个小东西。
And this is like 1998, 1999. EBay is really new. They had just gone public. People like Sara are calling on dial-up modems. And Sara said that the first thing that she did when she got onto eBay was enter "dining room table" into the search box.
那大概是1998、1999年。eBay那时还很新。他们才刚刚上市。像Sara这样的人还在用拨号调制解调器上网。Sara说，她上eBay后做的第一件事就是在搜索框里输入了“餐桌”。
And then I was amazed because suddenly there were all these pictures of tables, and you can just get them. Today it seems kind of old hat, but back then it really was exciting.
然后我惊呆了，因为突然之间出现了所有这些桌子的图片，而且你直接就能买到它们。今天这看起来像是陈词滥调了，但在当时真的很令人兴奋。
So at first, bidding on eBay was a lot like the barn auctions. Sara would bid on some piece of furniture and then ultimately did not have enough money to win. But she says that she was able to get a nice side table for $20. That gave her hope. And then one day--
起初，在eBay上竞拍很像谷仓拍卖会。Sara会竞拍一些家具，但最终还是没有足够的钱赢。但她说她最后以20美元买到了一张不错的小边桌。那给了她希望。直到有一天……
The listing was "round walnut table and two chairs." And I clicked on it, and the starting bid was like $10, but then the shipping was really low.
那个商品列表写着“圆核桃木桌和两把椅子”。我点击了它，起拍价大约是10美元，而且运费非常低。
I remember seeing a picture of it. It was kind of fancier than something we might normally go for, and the chairs looked great. It looked like what grown-up people would put in their house. Like, if we can put that table in here, that's it, that's the beginning. You could kind of see your kids sitting around that table someday.
我记得看到了它的照片。它比我们通常会选的东西要精致一些，而且椅子看起来棒极了。它看起来像是成年人会放在家里的那种东西。就像是，如果我们可以把那张桌子放在这儿，那就成了，那就是个开始。你能想象出有一天孩子们坐在那张桌子周围的样子。
So there's a brief bidding war, and Sara wins the table. She remembers it costing $20, Mike remembers it as $40. But the moment she won, that she's totally clear on.
于是发生了一场简短的竞拍大战，Sara赢得了那张桌子。她记得花了20美元，Mike记得是40美元。但赢的那一刻，她记得非常清楚。
Are you kidding? On that front, I was elated. That felt great. It just felt like, wow, I could furnish our whole house for $400.
开玩笑吗？在那方面，我欣喜若狂。感觉太棒了。感觉就像，哇，我可以花400美元把我们的整个房子都布置好。
I felt like suddenly, oh, we've been looking in the wrong places. We'd been going to these barn auctions, but people already know about that. But nobody knows about eBay yet. So yeah, I was really fired up about it.
我感觉突然间，哦，我们一直以来都找错地方了。我们一直去那些谷仓拍卖会，但人们已经知道那儿了。但还没人知道eBay。所以是的，我当时真的动力十足。
So a couple days pass. And one day Sara goes out to the mailbox, and there's a package. It's a box, like, half the size of a toaster.
过了几天。有一天Sara去取信，发现有一个包裹。那是一个盒子，大概只有烤面包机的一半大。
I was sort of like, oh, what's this? I brought it inside, and I came into the kitchen, and I opened up the box. And there was my walnut table and two chairs. And it was just as beautiful as it had been in the picture, but it was about 2 and 1/2 inches high. But it had the little velvet cushions, and it had a crocheted top on it. And it was from some guy in Maryland who makes doll furniture.
我当时有点困惑，哦，这是什么？我把它带进屋，走进厨房，打开了盒子。里面确实是我的核桃木桌和两把椅子。它和照片里一样漂亮，但只有2.5英寸高。不过它上面有丝绒小垫子，还有一个钩编的桌罩。那是马里兰州的一个人做的玩偶家具。
And I sat and I stared at it, dumbfounded for so long, trying to decide how I felt. That was the first thing when I was staring at the doll table. It was one of those do I laugh or do I cry moments. And then I do remember getting back on eBay and realizing that when you put in a general search term, there are still categories. Because I went and found the listing, and it was under doll furniture.
我坐着盯着它，目瞪口呆了很久，试图决定自己的心情。那是盯着玩偶桌子时的第一感觉。那是那种让我不知该笑还是该哭的时刻。后来我确实记得又上了eBay，意识到当你输入一个通用搜索词时，里面还有分类。因为我回过去找到了那个列表，它确实是在玩偶家具那一类下。
Next, she showed it to Mike. And Mike says that when she showed him the toy table, at first he couldn't even understand what it was that he was looking at. His brain could not process the information-- like, what is this?
接下来，她把它展示给Mike看。Mike说，当她给他看那个玩具桌时，起初他甚至不明白自己看到的是什么。他的大脑无法处理这些信息——像是，这是什么？
But then we were like, OK. That's fine. So we set it up in the dining room. So we had this big empty house and this tiny doll table with doll chairs set up in the dining room. And our friends started buying us little doll dishes and glasses.
但后来我们想，好吧。没关系。所以我们把它摆在了餐厅里。于是我们有一个空荡荡的大房子，餐厅里摆着一张放着玩偶椅子的微型玩偶桌。我们的朋友开始送我们小玩偶盘子和杯子。
So it was a perfect transaction except for that one thing.
所以除了那一件小事，这原本是一次完美的交易。
Yeah. Until the cardboard box arrived.
是的。直到那个纸板箱寄到。
I do remember wanting Mike to see what a beautiful table it was, even if it was the wrong size. Like, that did matter. It was a nice table.
我确实记得我想让Mike看看那是张多么漂亮的桌子，即使尺寸不对。那确实很重要。那是一张好桌子。
And I remember when our friends came over and they would all mock me, it really was important to me that they saw-- I mean, it was a beautiful-- the guy who made it is an artist. I'm going to give him that. And it was walnut, and it was hand-carved, and it had a nice little rim around it. And it was a miniature version of exactly what I wanted.
我记得当我们的朋友过来取笑我时，他们看到它——我的意思是，它是非常漂亮的——那个制作它的人是一位艺术家。这一点我要承认。它是核桃木的，是手工雕刻的，边缘还有漂亮的装饰。它正是我想要的那张桌子的微缩版本。
Well, today on our radio program, "Except For That One Thing," we have stories today where everything is just like you would dream, just like you would wish for, except for one pesky detail, one flaw. And the people involved, they have to decide if they can live with that flaw, that one problem in how things worked out, or if they cannot live with it.
今天在我们的广播节目“除了那一件小事”中，我们要分享一些故事，故事里的一切都如你所梦想、如你所愿，除了那一个恼人的细节，那一个瑕疵。当事人必须决定他们能否忍受那个瑕疵，那个事情发展过程中的问题，或者他们是否无法忍受。
That's what growing up is about, right? Living with things not being absolutely perfect. Am I just talking for myself here? I hope not. OK. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这就是成长的意义，对吧？忍受那些不尽完美的事物。是我在自言自语吗？希望不是。好的。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act 1, Run On Sentence. So lots of us have things about ourselves that we keep to ourselves that we assume people would see us differently if they knew about. And Mike Anderson had something like that, one thing about him in particular that he kept a secret, until one day it came out. Jessica Lussenhop explains.
第一幕，长句。我们许多人都有一些关于自己的事，我们把它们藏在心里，假设如果别人知道了，就会以不同的眼光看待我们。Mike Anderson就有过这样一件事，一件他保守秘密的事，直到有一天它曝光了。Jessica Lussenhop来为你讲述。
Mike Anderson was 36 years old, married, a suburban father of four. He owned a contracting business and built his family's modest, three-bedroom house in St. Louis from the ground up. He volunteered at church on the weekends and coached his son's football team. That changed last July. He was at home alone with his two-year-old daughter while his wife was away on a business trip.
Mike Anderson今年36岁，已婚，是郊区四个孩子的父亲。他拥有一家承包公司，并在圣路易斯从零开始建造了家里朴素的三居室房子。他周末在教堂做志愿者，并执教他儿子的足球队。这一切在去年七月改变了。当时他正独自在家陪着两岁大的女儿，而他的妻子去出差了。
I was sleeping. I was awoken. It was about 6 o'clock in the morning, woken by knocking at the door. And it was unusual knocking. It was the consistent knocking, the hard knocking. So I knew something was going on.
我在睡觉。我被吵醒了。大约是早上6点，被敲门声吵醒的。那是种不寻常的敲门声。是那种持续的、用力的敲门声。所以我知道出事了。
So I just stood at the top of the stairs for a moment. And finally I said, who is it? I'm in my boxers. And they said, marshals. Open it up, or it's coming down. Open up the door.
于是我在楼梯顶上站了一会儿。最后我说，是谁？我只穿了平角短裤。他们说，法警。开门，不然我们就破门了。把门打开。
As soon as I opened up the door, it was a small army. I mean, it was about eight of them. They had the shields. They had the helmets. They had the AR-15 style machine looking guns.
我一打开门，就是一支小军队。我是说，大约有八个人。他们带着盾牌。带着头盔。带着那种AR-15风格的机枪。
And they had the street blocked off. And I said, hey, man, you got the wrong person. And he just looked at me. He said, no, you're the right person.
他们封锁了街道。我说，嘿，伙计，你们找错人了。他只是看着我。他说，不，你就是我们要找的人。
The officer handcuffed him and asked, do you remember 13 years ago?
警官给他戴上手铐，问道，你还记得13年前的事吗？
I broke out in a sweat. They had to sit me down. And the only thing I could think about, what's my wife going to say? What's she going to think?
我惊出一身冷汗。他们不得不让我坐下。我唯一能想到的就是，我妻子会怎么说？她会怎么想？
I called her. And as soon as I called her, she was crying, what's going on? And I told her what was going on. I said, baby, this is from 13 years ago.
我给她打了电话。我一打通，她就在哭，发生了什么？我告诉了她发生的事。我说，宝贝，这是13年前的事了。
I'm freaking out-- I mean, screaming, crying.
我简直要疯了——我是说，尖叫、大哭。
This is Mike's wife, LaQonna. They've been married for six years.
这是Mike的妻子，LaQonna。他们结婚六年了。
I can hear the marshals in the background telling him he has to go. So he told me he loved me, and that was it.
我能听到背景里法警在告诉他必须走了。所以他告诉我他爱我，然后就挂了。
And when you heard "something from 13 years ago," did you understand what that meant at all? Or what were you thinking?
当你听到“13年前的事”时，你完全明白那意味着什么吗？还是你在想什么？
I didn't understand what it meant until the next day, when we had a talk with the attorney. Then I just passed out. Hit my head on the concrete.
直到第二天我们和律师谈过之后，我才明白那意味着什么。然后我就晕过去了。头撞到了水泥地上。
Here's what LaQonna learned. In 1999, Mike was arrested for armed robbery but never served his time because of what amounted to a clerical error. He was 22 years old when he and a friend held up a Burger King manager making a night deposit at a bank.
LaQonna了解到的是这些。1999年，Mike因武装抢劫被捕，但因为一个文书错误而没有服刑。他22岁时，和朋友在银行把一名正在进行夜间存款的汉堡王经理给抢了。
This wasn't a case of mistaken identity or wrongful conviction. Mike was there. Although his attorney instructed him not to discuss the details of the crime with me, Mike says he got caught up with the wrong crowd that night. Until then, he had no prior convictions and worked a full time job at AT&T.
这不是什么身份认同错误或冤假错案。Mike当时确实在那儿。虽然他的律师指导他不要和我讨论犯罪的细节，但Mike说那天他跟错了人。在此之前，他没有前科，在AT&T有一份全职工作。
In court, Mike testified that the robbery wasn't his idea and that the gun his friend was holding was just a BB gun. The police never actually recovered any weapons, but Mike was convicted of armed criminal action and robbery. The judge sentenced him to 13 years in prison. Mike filed a series of appeals, but in the end, the courts decided, nope. He had to serve his sentence. At the time, Mike was out on bail.
在法庭上，Mike作证说抢劫不是他的主意，他朋友拿的枪只是把BB弹枪。警方从未找到任何武器，但Mike被判武装犯罪和抢劫罪。法官判处他13年监禁。Mike提起了一系列上诉，但最终，法院驳回了。他必须服刑。当时，Mike正在保释中。
And here, something strange happened. At this point, Mike's bail should've been revoked, and he should have been arrested and taken to prison. But a warrant was never issued for that. Mike's attorney and the prosecutor appeared before a judge. Mike wasn't actually there himself.
在这里，发生了一件奇怪的事。此时，Mike的保释本应被撤销，他本应被逮捕并送进监狱。但从未发出逮捕令。Mike的律师和检察官出现在法官面前。Mike本人其实没在场。
From what I understand, the judge asked, where is Mr. Anderson? My attorney handed her the briefs and told her Mr. Anderson is currently out on bond. But the prosecuting attorney at that time hopped up and said, no, he's not out on bond. I checked, my office checked, he's currently in prison. And so that was it.
据我所知，法官问，Anderson先生在哪里？我的律师把案卷递给她，告诉她Anderson先生目前处于保释中。但当时的检察官跳出来说，不，他不在保释中。我查过了，我的办公室也查过了，他目前在监狱里。事情就是这样。
It was the prosecutor who told the judge that Mike was in custody, even though he wasn't, he was at home. Mike's attorney didn't say anything because he hadn't actually talked to Mike in a few days, and he thought maybe he really was back in prison-- until he talked to Mike on the phone.
是检察官告诉法官Mike在拘留中，尽管他并不在，他当时就在家。Mike的律师什么也没说，因为他其实已经好几天没和Mike说话了，他以为他真的回监狱了——直到他在电话里和Mike谈话。
He was shocked. He said, you aren't in jail? I said, no, I'm not. And so I was like, what are we supposed to do? Am I supposed to turn myself in?
他很震惊。他说，你不在监狱里？我说，不，我不在。所以我当时想，我们该怎么办？我是应该自首吗？
And it was just like, well, at this time, it's a mistake. They'll figure out their mistake. He says, temporary-- expect to be picked up. They're going to pick you up.
当时的情况就是，嗯，这是一个错误。他们会发现他们的错误。他说，暂时的——等着被抓吧。他们会来抓你的。
It wasn't unusual for it to take a couple of weeks for a warrant to get issued, but months then years passed. No one ever came and picked up Mike.
发出逮捕令需要几周时间并不罕见，但几个月甚至几年过去了。从来没有人来抓Mike。
Mike says he never really considered turning himself in. He figured they'd either come for him or they wouldn't. And if they didn't, OK. That was God's plan for him. His lawyer was vague about what he should do next. He left it up to Mike.
Mike说他从未真正考虑过自首。他想，他们要么会来找他，要么不会。如果他们不来，好吧。那是上帝对他计划的一部分。他的律师对于下一步该怎么做含糊其辞。这全由Mike自己决定。
But after the arrest, the trial, the months he spent in prison before bonding out, Mike decided to turn his life around. He went back to school and became a master carpenter. He got married and became a family man who checked homework and got his kids ready for bed every night. Mike never had another run-in with the law.
但在逮捕、审判以及在保释前在监狱里度过的几个月之后，Mike决定洗心革面。他回学校成为了一名木工大师。他结婚并成为了一个居家男人，每天晚上检查家庭作业并让孩子准备睡觉。Mike再也没有触犯过法律。
Did you feel like a fugitive during that time?
在那段时间里，你觉得自己像个逃犯吗？
No. I never felt like a fugitive. Because a fugitive is someone that's running from the law. I never ran from the law. I was there.
不。我从来没觉得自己像个逃犯。因为逃犯是那种躲避法律的人。我从来没躲避过法律。我就在那儿。
I registered my business through the state with a Social Security number, address, everything. I'm four streets over from the address that they had on file. I built a house over there. So there was never any running or strategy of, hey, I don't want to go here because there's going to be authorities. No, I lived a normal life.
我用社会保险号、地址等向州里注册了我的公司。我离他们档案里的地址只隔了四条街。我在那儿盖了房子。所以从来没有任何逃跑或策略，比如，嘿，我不想去这儿，因为会有当局。不，我过着正常的生活。
Did you feel relaxed right away? What was it like to sort of acclimate to this feeling that you're out and you may get to stay out?
你很快就感到放松了吗？适应这种“你出来了，可能还能待在外面”的感觉是什么样的？
It was 13 years of somewhat relief. But was it always in the back of my mind? Of course it was always in the back of my mind. Is that day coming any day now?
那13年里有某种解脱感。但它一直在我脑海深处吗？当然，它一直在我脑海深处。那一天会随时到来吗？
So like, you get pulled over for a traffic ticket. You run a red light, run a stop sign, or you didn't come into a complete stop. And they're running your information, and your heart's beating fast, like, man, are they going to know?
就像，你因为交通罚单被拦下。你闯了红灯，越过了停车标志，或者你没有完全停下来。他们在运行你的信息时，你的心跳很快，像，天哪，他们会知道吗？
And they come back, hey, Mr. Anderson. Hey, get your taillight fixed. Get your tags renewed. And that was it. And I was just like, wow. What's going on?
然后他们回来，嘿，Anderson先生。嘿，去修理你的尾灯。去更新你的车牌。事情就那样。我就想，哇。发生了什么？
In the end, the only reason that the Missouri Department of Corrections realized Mike was missing was because they were preparing to release him from prison. I called the Department of Corrections, the county's warrant officers, the original court where this happened, Missouri's Attorney General, and the state supreme court, and no one would say anything about how there was a record claiming that Mike was one of their inmates when he was, in fact, free.
最终，密苏里州惩教部意识到Mike失踪的唯一原因，是因为他们当时正准备将他从监狱释放。我打电话给惩教部、县逮捕令官员、发生此事的原始法院、密苏里州总检察长以及州最高法院，没有人愿意说明为什么会有一份记录声称Mike是他们的囚犯，而事实上他却是自由的。
Meanwhile, Mike and his wife still have not had a frank conversation about all this either. They haven't discussed the fact that Mike knew all those years that he might someday go back to prison but never told her.
同时，Mike和他的妻子对此事也从未进行过坦诚的交流。他们还没有讨论过Mike这些年来一直知道他可能有一天会回监狱，却从未告诉过她的事实。
Do you feel any sense of anger or wish that he had told you this earlier on?
你有没有感到愤怒或希望他早点告诉你？
I mean, that question arose in my head, just like, why he didn't tell me. I can't get mad at him because I understand why he hid it from me. He just wanted to protect me. So he didn't want to put too much on me that I couldn't handle. And that's just the type of person Mike is, too. He'll try to juggle everything by himself.
我是说，那个问题出现在我的脑海里，就是，他为什么不告诉我。我不能对他生气，因为我明白他为什么对我隐瞒。他只是想保护我。所以他不想给我带来太多我无法承受的东西。而且这正是Mike这种人的本性。他会尝试独自承担一切。
It feels a little strange that you guys haven't had that conversation.
你们俩没进行过那次谈话，感觉有点奇怪。
It's uncomfortable for me because I'm always embarrassed about it. That's not who I am now. It's not who I'll ever be. I just want to forget.
这让我感到不舒服，因为我一直为此感到尴尬。那不是现在的我。那永远不会是我。我只想忘记。
When I first visited Mike in November, he had to stay in his cell for about 22 hours a day in a huge penitentiary called Fulton Reception and Diagnostic, a gray building planted in the middle of farmland about two hours west of St. Louis. Usually clean cut, Mike had several months worth of beard on his chin.
十一月我第一次探望Mike时，他必须在位于圣路易斯以西两小时农田中间的一座名为富尔顿接收与诊断中心的巨大监狱里，每天待在牢房里大约22个小时。平时打扮利落的Mike，下巴上长了几个月的胡子。
August, the kids went to school, their first day of school. Missed that. September, missed me and my wife's anniversary on the 26th. November, my son turned seven on the 5th, and my daughter turned 11 on the 10th. I missed a lot-- missed a lot.
八月，孩子们上学，他们第一天上学。错过了。九月，错过了我和我妻子的周年纪念日，在26号。十一月，我儿子5号七岁生日，我女儿10号11岁生日。我错过了很多——错过了很多。
13 years without going to prison did exactly what you'd hope 13 years in prison will do for a person. Mike reformed, became a model citizen. Which raises the question, do we want to send him to prison?
13年没进监狱，起到了你希望13年监狱生活对一个人所能起到的完全一样的作用。Mike改过自新，成为了模范公民。这就引发了一个问题，我们真的想把他送进监狱吗？
It'll cost the state of Missouri about $20,000 a year to house and feed him. And if Mike's no longer a danger to society, what's the point of having him sit in a cell when he could be out working, paying taxes, and raising his kids? Tim Lohmar is the prosecuting attorney in St. Charles County, where Mike was sentenced-- although he's not the one who jumped up in court and said Mike was in prison. That prosecutor has passed away.
密苏里州每年要花大约2万美元来安置和喂养他。如果Mike不再对社会构成威胁，当他可以在外面工作、纳税并抚养孩子时，让他坐在牢房里有什么意义？Tim Lohmar是圣查尔斯县的检察官，Mike是在那里被判刑的——尽管他不是法庭上跳起来说Mike在监狱里的那个人。那位检察官已经去世了。
It still baffles me how this could have happened. But I think the state's interests are that this sentence has to be served.
我仍然对这种事怎么会发生感到困惑。但我认为州的利益在于这起判决必须得到执行。
So he's had this life. He's had children, started a small business. hasn't had any run-ins with the law. Some people would say that he's been rehabilitated. He shouldn't have to serve the sentence because it took so long.
所以他有了这样的生活。他有了孩子，开办了一家小公司。没有任何触犯法律的行为。有些人会说他已经改造好了。他不应该再服刑，因为这花的时间太长了。
Well, I can't say that that's not a reasonable thing for those people to think, especially his family, people who are close to him. Anybody who doesn't have sympathy for Mr. Anderson I think is not being genuine. It's a horrible tragedy for he and his family. So whether that spurs somebody at a higher pay grade than me to figure out a better way to do this, I don't know. You open Pandora's box.
嗯，我不能说这些人的想法不合理，尤其是他的家人，亲近他的人。任何不对Anderson先生抱有同情心的人，我认为都不是真诚的。这对我和他的家人来说都是一场可怕的悲剧。所以，无论是谁推动了比我级别更高的人去寻找更好的方法来解决这个问题，我都不知道。你打开了潘多拉魔盒。
If our system allowed for people to somehow-- whether it was their doing or somebody else's doing-- to delay their incarceration to see if they can rehabilitate and become a productive member of society, become a family man, I don't know how we would do that. I don't know where you stop. Where do you draw the line? That's not a precedent that I feel that we can set.
如果我们的系统允许人们以某种方式——无论是他们自己的所作所为还是别人的所作所为——推迟他们的监禁，看看他们是否能够改造并成为社会的生产力成员、成为居家男人，我不知道我们该如何做到这一点。我不知道你从哪里停止。你从哪里划定界限？那不是我觉得我们可以开创的先例。
Mike's family hired a lawyer who's filed a brief arguing that when the state forgot about Mike for 13 years, they violated his constitutional right to due process, or speedy punishment, that now suddenly taking Mike away from his life because of the state's, quote, "utter and complete failure to act defines cruelty," end quote. If that fails, Mike can petition Missouri governor Jay Nixon for clemency. He's only granted that once.
Mike的家人聘请了一名律师，提交了一份简报，辩称当州政府将Mike遗忘了13年时，他们侵犯了他获得正当程序或迅速惩罚的宪法权利，现在仅仅因为州政府引用“完全和彻底的行动失败”而将Mike从他的生活中带走，这定义为残忍。如果失败了，Mike可以向密苏里州州长Jay Nixon申请赦免。他只批准过一次。
Then there's the victim from the robbery. You'd think if anyone would have an opinion about whether Mike should serve his time or not, it would be him.
接下来是抢劫案的受害者。你会认为如果有人对Mike是否应该服刑有意见，那应该是他。
I hope someday that man can forgive me for what I was a part of. So I've always wanted to someway, somehow, reach out to him, but I always feared that it would be an intrusion. All I can do is just-- I'm sorry. I should have never been there that night.
我希望有一天那个人能原谅我参与了那件事。所以我一直想以某种方式，以某种方式接触他，但我总是担心这会是一种侵扰。我唯一能做的就是——我很抱歉。那天晚上我根本不该在那儿。
I first reported this story last summer for the St. Louis Riverfront Times. At that time, I couldn't find the victim. But then, right after my article published, he found me. His name is Dennis.
我去年夏天首次为《圣路易斯河滨时报》报道了这个故事。当时，我找不到受害者。但后来，就在我的文章发表后，他找到了我。他的名字叫Dennis。
I was sitting there back at work, eating my lunch and reading this magazine. Something about, oh, the guy was a Burger King manager at a night shift, and he got robbed out in St. Charles. And that's when I was like, wow, man, this is really trippy. That almost sounds like something that happened to me. And then when I got on down farther, then I was like, crap, they are talking about me.
我当时坐在那里回去工作，一边吃午餐一边读这本杂志。关于，哦，那个家伙是一个上夜班的汉堡王经理，他在圣查尔斯被抢劫了。那时我就想，哇，伙计，这真的很不可思议。这几乎听起来像发生在我身上的事。然后当我读到后面时，我就想，该死，他们在谈论我。
When he first contacted me, Dennis sent me an email saying, I was that victim. Why don't you talk to me, and I'll tell you how bad it screwed up my life. When we finally met, Dennis told me that getting robbed at gunpoint left him deeply paranoid. He even moved a few times, thinking the robbers might come looking for him to keep him from testifying.
当他第一次联系我时，Dennis发了一封电子邮件，说，我就是那个受害者。你为什么不和我谈谈，我会告诉你这让我的生活变得多么糟糕。当我们最终见面时，Dennis告诉我，在枪口下被抢劫让他变得深感偏执。他甚至搬了几次家，认为抢劫者可能会来找他以阻止他作证。
It started kind of getting to me a little bit, to where I wasn't sleeping at nights. And it kind of just escalated from there. I didn't want to be there at work no more, refused to take any money back to the bank, not at nighttime, anyway. I just didn't trust anybody, didn't want to do anything, didn't want to be anywhere. I just pretty much wanted to just be by myself.
它开始有点困扰我了，甚至到了我晚上睡不着觉的地步。它就这样升级了。我不想再在那儿工作了，拒绝把任何钱带回银行，至少晚上不带。我不相信任何人，不想做任何事，不想去任何地方。我几乎只想独自一人。
Dennis said he had problems in his life before the robbery-- with his marriage, with drinking. But he says after, they got worse. His marriage fell apart. And so when Dennis found out that Mike never served his sentence, he got pretty angry.
Dennis说他在抢劫前生活中就有问题——婚姻、酗酒。但他说是那之后，情况变糟了。他的婚姻破裂了。所以当Dennis发现Mike从未服刑时，他变得非常生气。
But then the more I thought about it, it was like, what you're doing to him is not right. He wasn't out robbing other people, doing this, that, and the other. He seemed to have gotten his life together.
但后来我越想越觉得，你对他所做的事是不对的。他没有出去抢劫其他人，做这做那。他似乎已经把生活调整好了。
You've got to give the guy a little bit of slack. I mean, yeah, he screwed up when he was little. But the law dropped the ball. The law ought to drop it completely. They need to leave the man alone.
你得给这家伙一点余地。我是说，是的，他年轻的时候搞砸了。但法律搞砸了。法律应该完全放下它。他们需要让那个人安宁。
When you tell people that that's how you feel about it, does it surprise them?
当你告诉别人这就是你的感受时，他们会感到惊讶吗？
It's the weirdest thing. As I was sitting downstairs rereading that article one day for my daughter, she goes, Dad, we read this in school the other day. I was like, oh yeah? I said, oh.
这是最奇怪的事情。有一天我为我女儿重读那篇文章时，她说，爸爸，我们前几天在学校读过这个。我说，哦是吗？我说，哦。
But at the time, she didn't know it was me. Because I just never talk about it. She said that she didn't think it was right, what they're doing to him now. And pretty much her whole class agreed with her.
但在当时，她不知道那是我。因为我从来不谈论它。她说她认为现在他们对他所做的事是不对的。而且她整个班级都同意她的观点。
Then Dennis told her that he was the Burger King manager in that article and that he felt the same way she did. Two days after that conversation, I went back to the prison to talk to Mike. I told him what Dennis and his daughter said, that the state should let him go. He was overwhelmed.
然后Dennis告诉她，他就是那篇文章里的汉堡王经理，而且他感觉和她一样。在那次谈话两天后，我回到监狱和Mike谈话。我告诉他Dennis和他女儿说的话，州政府应该放他走。他不知所措。
Wow, that's-- all I can say is praise, God. Thank God for that. And I don't know what to say. (CHOKING UP) I don't.
哇，那是——我唯一能说的就是赞美上帝。感谢上帝。我不知道该说什么。（哽咽）我不知道。
He told me he was really sorry to be bothering Dennis by reminding him of the past.
他告诉我，他真的很抱歉通过提醒Dennis过去的事情而打扰他。
I appreciate him. I never want him to ever be-- this brought back to him. That's my fault. I appreciate him for that-- his daughter and the class. His daughter could be affected by that, you know? That's not something that I ever-- that's never my intent, and I don't want that.
我感激他。我从不希望他曾经被——这再次带回到他身上。那是我的错。我感激他——他的女儿和班级。他的女儿可能会因此受到影响，你知道吗？这不是我曾经想过的——那从来不是我的意图，我不想那样。
Mike is afraid of falling into the daily routines of prison. So aside from his church group, he doesn't interact much with the other inmates. He won't do things like watch TV with them or play cards. He also doesn't like writing his family letters.
Mike害怕陷入监狱的日常琐事中。所以除了他的教会小组，他不怎么和其他囚犯互动。他不会和他们一起看电视或打牌。他也不喜欢给家人写信。
I try not to write anybody because I don't want to get used to this. I don't want my wife coming up here to visit me. She wanted to come up here the 1st of this month, and I said, no, don't do it.
我尽量不给任何人写信，因为我不想习惯这里。我不希望我妻子来这里看我。她想在这个月1号来，我说，不，别这么做。
For eight years, we've never been apart. And I don't want her getting this image of me. I don't want anybody thinking this is who I am.
八年来，我们从未分开过。我不希望她得到这种对我的印象。我不希望任何人认为这就是我。
If you could go back, would you turn yourself in at 22?
如果可以重来，你会选择在22岁时自首吗？
If I would have known this, yes. Yes. If it would have been something-- oh, definitely. Like I said, I would have rather done it then. I was 22, 23 at the time, didn't have any children, didn't have a wife, didn't have a mortgage, didn't have a car payment. The hurt would have been less then.
如果我早知道会这样，会的。会的。如果那件事是——哦，绝对。就像我说的，我宁愿那时候做。我那时才22、23岁，没有孩子，没有妻子，没有房贷，没有车贷。那时候的痛苦会少一些。
No one, financially or physically, depended on me. It's almost like I feel like I've abandoned my job as a man and as a father. Because my mom, my wife, my kids, they're doing the same time I'm doing.
没有人在经济上或身体上依赖我。几乎感觉我抛弃了作为男人和父亲的职责。因为我妈妈、我妻子、我的孩子，他们都在服我正在服的刑。
As it stands now, Mike's sentence will keep him in until 2026. He'll be nearly 50 when he gets out. His two-year-old will just be starting high school. Accepting all that, it's just too crushing to consider.
目前的状况是，Mike的刑期将让他待到2026年。他出去时快50岁了。他两岁大的孩子那时才刚上高中。接受这一切，真的太让人崩溃了。
I have to look at it like, no matter what, God's got me. I wake up every time the doors pop. Every time the intercom comes on, every time my name is called, I feel it's my time. I'm going home.
我不得不这样看，无论如何，上帝保佑我。每一次门响时我都醒了。每一次对讲机响起，每一次我的名字被点到，我都觉得是我的时间。我要回家了。
How long do you think you can kind of keep up that mindset?
你觉得你还能保持那种心态多久？
I'm going to keep up that mindset till the day I walk out of here. I have to. I can't sit here and think that I'll be here for 13 years. There's no way. Everything that I've been allowed to do that I've accomplished. It seems like it would be all for nothing.
我会保持那种心态直到我走出这里的日子。我必须保持。我不能坐在这里想我还要在这里待13年。没可能的。我被允许做的一切，我所取得的一切成就。好像这一切都付诸东流了。
In November, Mike and his wife both expected he'd be home for Christmas. Now she just assures herself it'll be very soon. They talk on the phone almost every day. But they both told me they figure they'll finally discuss Mike's original crime, and the fact he kept it from her all those years, face-to-face, once this is all over, once he gets home.
十一月，Mike和他的妻子都以为他会回家过圣诞节。现在她只是确信那会很快。他们几乎每天都通电话。但他们俩都告诉我，他们想等这一切结束、他回家后，面对面讨论Mike当年的罪行，以及他瞒着她那么多年的事实。
Jessica Lussenhop, she's the managing editor at the Riverfront Times in St. Louis. Since we first broadcast that story a year ago, a lot has changed for Mike Anderson and his family.
Jessica Lussenhop，她是圣路易斯《河滨时报》的主编。自从一年前我们第一次播出那个故事以来，Mike Anderson和他的家人的情况发生了很多变化。
Four little children are back in the arms of their father tonight. They haven't seen him since US Marshals came to take him back to prison last July.
四个小孩子今晚又回到了父亲的怀抱。自从去年七月美国法警来把他带回监狱后，他们就没见过他。
That's right. Mike Anderson was released this past May when a judge decided keeping him in prison was a waste of taxpayer money and that, quote, "it would unnecessarily punish an obviously rehabilitated man." Then six months after being released, Mike was back behind bars.
没错。Mike Anderson在去年五月被释放，当时一名法官决定让他留在监狱是浪费纳税人的钱，并称“这将不必要地惩罚一个显然已经改造好的人。”然后在被释放六个月后，Mike又回到了铁窗之后。
He was leaving a restaurant, 1:00 in the morning. And he was stopped by police, identified as a man who had just stolen a purse. Mike Anderson said he was innocent. He was nowhere near the scene of the crime when the crime happened.
他凌晨一点离开一家餐馆时被警方拦下，被认定为刚偷了一个钱包的人。Mike Anderson说他是无辜的。案发时他根本不在犯罪现场。
He'd said he'd been in the restaurant with his wife at a party his employer was throwing. He was charged with felony, second degree robbery. Then three months after being arrested, new evidence emerged. Surveillance footage proved Mike had been telling the truth all along. Here's Circuit Attorney Jennifer Joyce.
他说他当时和妻子在他雇主举办的派对上。他被指控犯有重罪，二级抢劫。但在被捕三个月后，新的证据出现了。监控录像证明Mike一直说的是真话。这是巡回检察官Jennifer Joyce。
My apologies to Mr. Anderson. Mr. Anderson did not commit this crime.
我对Anderson先生表示歉意。Anderson先生没有犯罪。
And so two times, Mike Anderson became a free man. Coming up after the break, a date that is close, so close to being perfect, except for one thing. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
所以两次，Mike Anderson重获自由。稍事休息后，一个几乎完美的日期，除了那一件小事。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Except For That One Thing." Stories where everything is perfect, except for one inconvenient detail.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“除了那一件小事”。一切都很完美，除了一个不方便的细节的故事。
We have arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, Not Okay Cupid. This is a piece of fiction by BJ Novak-- a piece of fiction that, with his help, we've turned into a little radio drama. It takes place at a restaurant. Hold on, let me cue restaurant sound, please.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，Not Okay Cupid。这是BJ Novak的一篇小说——这篇小说，在他的帮助下，我们把它变成了一个广播剧。故事发生在一间餐馆。等等，让我把餐馆的音效调出来。
[CHATTER]
[聊天声]
There we go. OK. Here's our story.
好了。OK。这就是我们的故事。
OK. Now, you, sir.
OK。现在，先生，你。
Julie finished the second-to-last half sip of her third complicated cocktail.
Julie喝完了她第三杯复杂鸡尾酒中倒数第二口的最后一点。
Yes?
是？
You, sir. Now, I am-- OK. [LAUGHS] I feel like we've only talked about me, but I don't know anything about you, other than that you're very charming, and well, very cute, of course. Don't let that go to your head. Shouldn't have said that. Shouldn't have said that.
先生，你。现在，我——OK。（笑）我觉得我们一直都在聊我，但我除了知道你很迷人，嗯，当然还有很可爱之外，对你一无所知。别让这冲昏了你的头脑。我不该那么说的。我不该那么说的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
OK. If this is my-- [LAUGHS] OK. What do you do?
OK。如果这是我的——（笑）OK。你是做什么的？
What do I do? You mean, what is my job?
我是做什么的？你是说，我的职业是什么吗？
Sorry. I hate that question, too. It's like, is this a date or an interview, right?
抱歉。我也讨厌这个问题。这就像，这是约会还是面试，对吧？
He finished his bite of sauce-soaked broccolini and answered.
他吃完了一口泡在酱汁里的西兰花，回答道。
[INAUDIBLE] lord.
[听不清] 主。
Hm? All I heard was "lord."
嗯？我只听到了“主”。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, OK. OK. This is fun. Are you a landlord? Because I do not have the best history getting along with landlords. My first apartment--
哦，OK。OK。这很有趣。你是房东吗？因为我在和房东相处方面记录不太好。我的第一间公寓——
I am not a landlord.
我不是房东。
Are you a drug lord?
你是毒枭？
Julie stroke-poked the side of his face with her finger.
Julie用手指轻敲了一下他脸颊的一侧。
Because that could be a problem.
因为那可能会是个问题。
No.
不。
You're not the Lord, are you? Because I haven't gone to temple since my bat mitzvah. Don't tell my grandma.
你不是“主”吧？因为我自从受洗礼后就没去过寺庙了。别告诉我奶奶。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
She could tell he was laughing just to be nice. And she liked that more than if he had laughed from finding her funny. A nice guy, now that would be a real change of pace for her.
她看得出来他笑只是为了礼貌。而她喜欢这一点，比他因为觉得她有趣而笑要好得多。一个好人，那对他来说真是节奏上的真正改变。
Then what kind of lord are you anyways, huh? [LAUGHS]
那你到底是哪种“主”啊，哈？（笑）
God, she was a bit tipsy, wasn't she?
天哪，她有点醉了，不是吗？
I'm a warlord.
我是军阀。
Interesting. Now, I don't know exactly what this is. But I want to learn. So what exactly is a warlord?
有趣。现在，我不太确切知道这是什么。但我想要学习。所以，军阀到底是什么？
She rested her chin playfully on a V of two upturned palms.
她俏皮地把下巴放在两手向上翻成的V字上。
Educate me.
教教我。
OK. Can you picture where the Congo is on a map?
OK。你能想象出地图上刚果在哪儿吗？
Julie exaggerated.
Julie夸张地说。
Kind of.
算是吧。
This is Africa.
这是非洲。
He pointed to an imaginary map in the air between them.
他指着他们之间空气中虚构的地图。
This is the Indian Ocean. This is the Democratic Republic of the Congo. This is just regular Congo.
这是印度洋。这是刚果民主共和国。这是普通的刚果。
Wha-- what? Hold up.
什——什么？等等。
I know. That's just how it is. I didn't name them. [CHUCKLES] Anyway, this, all this here, this is what I control.
我知道。事情就是这样。名字不是我起的。（轻笑）总之，这里，这一切，就是我控制的范围。
So you're like the governor of it?
所以你就像那儿的州长？
No. There are areas of the world, Julie, where it will show up on your map as a certain country. But in reality, no government is in control of that region in any real way. They cannot collect taxes. They cannot enforce laws. Do you follow?
不。世界上有些地区，Julie，在你的地图上它显示为某个国家。但实际上，没有任何政府能以任何真实的方式控制该地区。他们无法征税。他们无法执行法律。你明白吗？
Mhm.
嗯。
Julie nodded.
Julie点了点头。
The people that are in charge are the warlords. They-- we-- bribe, kidnap, indoctrinate, torture, and what am I forgetting? What's the fifth one? Oh, kill. [CHUCKLES] It's weird that I forgot that one.
掌权的人就是军阀。他们——我们——贿赂、绑架、洗脑、折磨，还有我忘了什么？第五个是什么？哦，杀人。（轻笑）我忘了那个真奇怪。
We kill the population of any region that falls above a certain threshold of natural resources but below a certain threshold of government protection. It's not exactly that simple, Julie. But basically that determines where I'm based. Once those conditions reach that level, me and my team, we show up and terrorize that area until the entire population is either dead, subdued, or ideally, one of our soldiers. Ideally-ideally, dream scenario, a child soldier.
我们会杀死任何自然资源超过一定阈值但政府保护低于一定阈值的地区的居民。并不完全那么简单，Julie。但基本上这就决定了我的驻地。一旦条件达到那个水平，我和我的团队，我们就会出现，并恐吓那个地区，直到全体人口要么死亡、屈服，或者理想情况下，成为我们的士兵。最理想的情况，梦想场景，童子军。
But that does not sound legal.
但那听起来不合法。
No. It isn't legal at all. Have you been listening?
不。根本不合法。你一直在听吗？
Oh, um--
哦，嗯——
Julie blushed and rotated her fork on her napkin in a four-point turn so that she would have something to focus on besides her embarrassment.
Julie脸红了，在餐巾纸上用叉子转了一个四点转弯，这样她就可以专注于别的事情而不是她的尴尬。
This is a show of force outside the ability of any government to enforce its laws.
这是一种超出任何政府执行其法律能力的武力展示。
He went on and on. The words "rape" and "limbs" came up more than on any other date she could remember.
他继续滔滔不绝。词语“强奸”和“肢体”出现的次数比她记忆中任何一次约会都要多。
Have you ever scene a picket fence made of limbs?
你见过用肢体做的尖桩篱笆吗？
No. But what about, like, the international community? Don't they ever pressure you to stop or-- or something?
没有。但是，像国际社会呢？他们难道从来不给你压力让你停止吗——或者——之类的？
Yes, sure. For example, there was this thing about me on Twitter a while ago. Are you on Twitter?
是的，当然。比如，前段时间Twitter上有关于我的事情。你玩Twitter吗？
She said she was but didn't check it often.
她说她在玩，但不太常看。
Yeah, I am. But I don't check it often.
是的，我也是。但我不太常看。
Same here. I have an account, but I can never figure out if it's a thing I do or not. Anyway, I was trending. Do you know what that is?
我也是。我有账号，但我永远无法弄清楚我是否真的在用它。总之，我上了热搜。你知道那是什么吗？
Yeah.
知道。
I'll be honest, it weirded me out. I got into this pattern where I was checking my name every two seconds. And there were, like, 45 new mentions of me-- all negative.
说实话，它让我感到怪怪的。我进入了一种模式，每两秒钟就查一次我的名字。大约有45条关于我的新提到——全是负面的。
You can't let yourself fall into that.
你不能让自己陷入那种状态。
Exactly. Anyway, it passed. You know Twitter, before long everyone's onto the next thing.
确实。总之，它过去了。你知道Twitter，用不了多久大家都会转向下一个话题。
What about [GULP] um, the ethics of it? How do you feel about that? Doesn't that trouble you?
那关于（吞咽）嗯，道德方面呢？你对此怎么想？那不困扰你吗？
The warlord gestured to Julie with his fork.
军阀用叉子向Julie示意。
That top you're wearing-- Anthropologie?
你穿的那件上衣——Anthropologie？
H&M, but thank you.
H&M，但谢谢。
Even better. Do you know the conditions in the factories that made that top you're wearing? Do you ever think about that?
那更好。你知道穿那件上衣的工厂里的条件吗？你考虑过吗？
Yeah, OK. No. That's not-- nice try. Just because-- no. No. And yes, I know this phone right here that I use every day. But no-- no. You can't-- it doesn't help anything to equate-- look-- there's no excuse. But that also does not mean--
是的，OK。不。那不是——好尝试。仅仅因为——不。不。而且是的，我知道我每天用的这部手机。但——不。你不能——等同起来没有任何帮助——听着——没有任何借口。但这也不意味着——
(WHISPERING) Just in case you're thinking about dessert.
（耳语）以防你在考虑甜点。
The waitress dropped off two stiff sheets of artisan paper in front of Julie and the warlord.
服务员在Julie和军阀面前放下两张坚硬的艺术纸。
Remember when they used to ask first if you wanted to see a dessert menu? Now everyone just ambushes you with a dessert menu without asking. When did that start?
还记得他们过去先问你是否想看甜点菜单的时候吗？现在每个人都直接用甜点菜单伏击你，不问一声。那是什么时候开始的？
I know. Everyone started doing it at the same time, too.
我知道。每个人也都在同一时间开始做这件事。
Yes.
是的。
How does stuff like that happen?
那种事情是怎么发生的？
I don't know.
不知道。
Everywhere just [SNAPS FINGERS] changing their policy at the exact same time.
到处都在（弹响手指）完全同时改变他们的政策。
I have no idea. Better get Malcolm Gladwell on that.
我不知道。最好让Malcolm Gladwell去调查一下。
I know, right?
我知道，对吧？
They both scanned the menus.
他们都扫描了菜单。
Let's see--
让我看看——
Each pair of eyes starting in the unhelpful middle of the dessert menu for some no-reason, then tipsily circling around and around until most of the important words had been absorbed.
每双眼睛都从甜点菜单毫无意义的中间开始，然后醉醺醺地绕着圈，直到大部分重要词汇被吸收。
I have never understood flourless chocolate cake. Is flour such a bad thing? I mean, compared to the other things in chocolate cake?
我从来没理解过无粉巧克力蛋糕。面粉是那么糟糕的东西吗？我是说，比起巧克力蛋糕里的其他东西？
You want to split that?
你想分吃那个吗？
Flour is probably the least unhealthy thing I can think of in a chocolate cake. Is that supposed to be the point, that the whole cake is just all eggs and sugar and butter?
面粉可能是巧克力蛋糕里我能想到的最不健康的东西了。这难道就是重点，整个蛋糕全是鸡蛋、糖和黄油吗？
And anyway, who cares? It's chocolate cake. We know it's not a health food. Use whatever ingredients you want. All it has to do is taste good. We don't need to know how you did it, just make it.
总之，谁在乎呢？它是巧克力蛋糕。我们知道它不是保健食品。想用什么配料就用什么。它只需要味道好就行。我们不需要知道你怎么做的，只要把它做好。
You want to maybe split that?
你想也许分吃那个吗？
We shall split the flourless chocolate cake.
我们要分吃无粉巧克力蛋糕。
Great.
太棒了。
So do you get to travel a lot?
那你有很多旅行的机会吗？
Not as much as I'd like. Now and then we'll reach some ceasefire, especially after some big massacre, and things get quiet for a bit. That's what allowed me to take some time off, travel, meet you, stuff like that. Oh, I meant to say, you look even better in person than in your profile picture.
不如我想要的那么多。时不时地我们会达成某种停火协议，特别是在大屠杀之后，事情会安静一会儿。这让我有时间休息、旅行、见你之类的事情。哦，我想说，你本人看起来比你照片里还好。
Oh, thank you.
哦，谢谢。
Yeah. I've been meaning to tell you that. It's a nice surprise. Rare that it goes in that direction.
是的。我一直想告诉你。这真是个惊喜。很少有往那个方向发展的。
Hah, well, thanks. Um, same. Don't let it go to your head.
哈，嗯，谢谢。嗯，我也是。别让它冲昏了头脑。
Thanks. So, lost my train of thought.
谢谢。所以，我忘了刚才想说什么了。
Ceasefires?
停火？
Right. So you know, ceasefires, they never stick.
对。所以你知道，停火，它们从来都不能持久。
Yes. I think I saw something about that on Jon Stewart. That must be frustrating.
是的。我想我在Jon Stewart的节目上看到过类似的内容。那一定很令人沮丧。
It is. Thank you, Julie. That's exactly the right word. It's very frustrating.
确实。谢谢，Julie。那正是最恰当的词。非常令人沮丧。
Flourless chocolate cake.
无粉巧克力蛋糕。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Can I get you anything else? Another drink?
我还能为你拿点什么吗？再来一杯？
I really shouldn't. Are you OK to drive, by the way?
我真不该喝了。顺便问一下，你开车没问题吗？
I have a driver.
我有司机。
Julie ordered a fourth and final cocktail.
Julie点了第四杯也是最后一杯鸡尾酒。
BJ Novak, that story, "Julie and the Warlord," is from his book of short stories called One More Thing-- Stories and Other Stories . Our amazing actors-- Alison Brie played Julie. Tunde Adebimpe was the warlord.
BJ Novak，那个故事“Julie与军阀”，来自他的短篇小说集《再多一件——故事与其他故事》。我们出色的演员——Alison Brie饰演Julie。Tunde Adebimpe饰演军阀。
Act 3, Hungry Hungry People. There was a period in the early 1900s in our country when meat was actually scarce because of huge waves of immigrants coming in. Plus, there was also a growing demand for us to export meat to other countries. And meat was scarce enough that the thinkers and journalists and politicians of the day didn't just call it a meat shortage. The problem was commonly referred to by this loftier, more zen-like name, the Meat Question.
第三幕，饥饿的人们。我们国家在20世纪初有一段时间，由于大量移民涌入，肉类确实很稀缺。此外，还有出口肉类到其他国家的日益增长的需求。肉类稀缺到当时的思想家、记者和政客们并不只是称其为肉类短缺。这个问题通常被称为一个更高尚、更禅意的名称——肉类问题。
Jon Mooallem wrote a long story about this for The Atavist online. He says that there would be newspaper editorials about what are we going to do about the Meat Question. It pops up in congressional testimony on unrelated subjects. People will say, well, you know, it's just like the Meat Question. The question being, how are we going to raise enough meat for all the people here?
Jon Mooallem为在线媒体《The Atavist》写了一篇关于此的长文。他说，当时会有关于我们要如何处理肉类问题的社论。它出现在关于无关主题的国会证词中。人们会说，嗯，你知道，这就像肉类问题。问题是，我们要如何为这里的所有人筹集足够的肉？
Jon Mooallem talked to This American Life producer Alex Blumberg about all this. He said it wasn't like American industry wasn't trying to produce more meat.
Jon Mooallem与《美国生活》的制片人Alex Blumberg谈到了这一切。他说，这并不是说美国工业没有在努力生产更多的肉。
This is like Upton Sinclair, The Jungle era. So you have the industry just ramping up and trying to become as efficient as it can. But it's just not happening. It's just the supply was still being dwarfed by the demand. And--
这就像Upton Sinclair的《屠场》时代。所以工业界正在加紧努力，试图变得尽可能高效。但情况并不乐观。供应量仍然被需求量所压倒。而且——
No matter how many rats and human fingers they added, they just couldn't produce enough meat.
无论他们添加了多少只老鼠和人手指，他们就是生产不出足够的肉。
Well, right. And people were actually a little bit worried. There were rumors that Germans were eating dogs and all this stuff. And could it happen here, too?
嗯，对。而且人们实际上有点担心。有传言说德国人在吃狗肉之类的事。这种事会发生在这里吗？
And in that way, it was also really an existential crisis for the country at the same time because literally, we had gone all the way west. People talk about the frontier being closed. There wasn't a sense that there was more to scoop up in America. Passenger pigeons and buffalo had been decimated. You had forests that had been overlogged and destroyed.
而且在这种意义上，它同时也是这个国家的某种生存危机，因为字面意义上，我们已经一路向西了。人们谈论边疆的关闭。人们并不觉得在美国还有更多可以挖掘的东西。旅鸽和水牛已经被消灭了。你的森林被过度砍伐和破坏了。
And then suddenly, about 1900, 1910, this kind of regret started to seep into the culture where people were kind of looking around and wondering, well, what have we done? And what did that say about the country at the turn of the century if no one could come up with some innovative idea to kind of hit this problem head on and solve it?
然后突然间，大约1900年、1910年，这种遗憾开始渗入文化中，人们环顾四周，想知道，嗯，我们做了什么？如果没人能提出某种创新的想法来正面解决这个问题，那在世纪之交对这个国家意味着什么？
OK. So there's the problem. It's a problem that's crying out for bold solutions. And low and behold, somebody comes forth with a bold solution.
好的。所以问题就在这儿。这是一个呼唤大胆解决方案的问题。瞧，有人提出了一个大胆的解决方案。
Right. It was a very bold solution. The solution was hippopotamuses.
对。那是一个非常大胆的解决方案。解决方案是河马。
[LAUGHS] Explain. Explain further. How are hippopotamuses going to fix the problem?
（笑）解释一下。再解释一下。河马要如何解决这个问题？
OK. It was really going to be cool. The problem basically is we don't have any more land. We've hit the Pacific Ocean. So what we need to do is look at land that right now looks completely worthless and find a way to extract the energy that's hidden in that land and turn it into meat.
OK。那真的会很酷。问题基本在于我们没有更多的土地了。我们已经撞到了太平洋。所以我们需要做的是，着眼于目前看起来完全没有价值的土地，找到一种方法来提取隐藏在那里的能量，并将其转化为肉。
The swamps all along the Gulf Coast-- you can't have a cow trudging through a swamp, eating muddy water. It's not going to survive. You can't graze it there. But you could take a hippopotamus and put it in that landscape, and it would eat aquatic plants.
墨西哥湾沿岸的所有沼泽地——你不能让奶牛在沼泽中跋涉，吃着浑浊的水。它不会存活。你不能在那里放牧。但你可以把一只河马放在那片景观中，它会吃水生植物。
So the hippopotamus was this-- today we'd call it a very disruptive technology. It was going to turn something that seemed worthless and leverage it into millions of tons of meat to solve this big crisis.
所以河马是这个——今天我们会称之为一种非常有破坏性的技术。它将把看起来毫无价值的东西转化为数百万吨肉，以解决这个大危机。
And there's two main sort of characters at the center of your story who were behind this-- Frederick Burnham and a man named Fritz Duquesne. And both of them have very sort of colorful back histories, but they both spent time in Africa, were sort of very, very talented outdoor guide, survival guide scouts.
你故事中心有两位主要人物支持这一点——Frederick Burnham和名叫Fritz Duquesne的人。他们都有非常丰富多彩的过去，但他们都在非洲待过，是非常优秀的户外向导、生存向导侦察兵。
Yeah. Someone had called Burnham the most complete human being who ever lived, I guess you would say, like a shorthand.
对。有人称Burnham为有史以来最完整的人类，我想你会说，像一种速记法。
And these guys were actually, you write-- for much of their lives, they were mortal enemies. For a large part of their lives, they were actually spies. They fought against each other. But they had actually come together at this point over this idea, the hippo idea. And then at a certain point, this idea, with their help, makes its way to Congress.
你写道，这些人实际上——他们生活的大部分时间里，他们是死对头。他们生活中很大一部分时间实际上是间谍。他们互相斗争。但他们在这个想法上走到了一起，即河马想法。然后在那之后，这个想法在他们的帮助下进入了国会。
Yeah. So a congressman named Robert Broussard from Louisiana-- his constituents called him Cousin Bob. He insisted he was cousins with half of the people in his district. And Broussard brought a bill to the Agriculture Committee of the House of Representatives to ask for $250,000 for the importation of useful animals, the hippopotamus being-- that was the example they felt ready to go ahead with, the common hippopotamus.
对。所以路易斯安那州的一位国会议员Robert Broussard——他的选民称他为Broussard表亲。他坚持说他和他选区里一半的人是表亲。Broussard向众议院农业委员会提交了一项法案，要求拨款25万美元用于进口有用的动物，河马就是他们觉得准备好付诸实施的那个例子，普通河马。
And Jon writes that everyone involved in this idea had their own motivations. For Congressman Bob Broussard, it was to solve a problem in his district-- the water hyacinth. It came to New Orleans during the World's Fair, which was also known as the World Industrial and Cotton Centennial, when a group of Japanese visitors had given a bunch of water hyacinths away as gifts.
Jon写道，参与这个想法的每个人都有他们自己的动机。对于Broussard议员来说，是为了解决他选区的一个问题——水葫芦。它是在世博会期间来到新奥尔良的，世博会也被称为世界工业和棉花百年纪念会，当时一群日本访客送出了一堆水葫芦作为礼物。
And the water hyacinth, basically, was a plague in the bayous of Louisiana. It was choking all these rivers and stopped shipping. Boats couldn't get through with cargo. Fish died because there was no oxygen left in the water.
水葫芦基本上是路易斯安那州河口的一场瘟疫。它堵塞了所有的河流，阻碍了航运。船只无法运送货物。鱼类死亡，因为水中没有氧气了。
And there were all sorts of attempts to kill the flower, none of which worked. The US War Department was on the job, just even pouring oil all over the flower, hoping to kill it. So the idea was the hippos could be brought in, put in the rivers. They'd suck up all this aquatic vegetation. And so they'd literally ingest one problem and convert it into the solution for the other problem, which was the meat crisis.
人们尝试了各种方法来消灭这种花，没有一种奏效。美国战争部当时就在做这份工作，甚至把油倒在花上，希望能杀死它。所以想法是把河马引进来，放到河里。它们会吸干所有这些水生植被。所以它们实际上会吞食一个问题，并将其转化为另一个问题的解决方案，也就是肉类危机。
Two birds.
一箭双雕。
Exactly. As I say, it was a perversely elegant win-win, the hippopotamuses.
正是。正如我所说，这是一次极其优雅的双赢，河马。
It does. It makes a lot of sense.
确实。很有道理。
Yeah.
对。
Except that it's utterly ridiculous, right?
除了它完全荒谬，对吧？
OK. Right, it's utterly ridiculous. But can you tell me why?
OK。对，完全荒谬。但你能告诉我为什么吗？
Well, it's just-- hippopotamus is just a ridiculous thing.
嗯，这只是——河马就是一种荒谬的东西。
OK. So I don't disagree with what you're saying, but you're telling me why it sounds ridiculous. You're not telling me why it is ridiculous. And I'm not saying that it's not ridiculous. OK? I'm just saying that I can't yet locate exactly why it is ridiculous.
OK。我不同意你的说法，但你告诉了我它听起来为什么荒谬。你没有告诉我它为什么荒谬。而且我并不是说它不荒谬。OK？我只是说我还没能定位它究竟为什么荒谬。
And actually, as you looked into it, there was a lot of reasons why this plan should actually work.
而且事实上，正如你调查的那样，这个计划有很多理由实际上应该行得通。
And maybe not even why it would work, but there's a logic to it. I was surprised by how much logic there was to it. That was what drew me in.
也许甚至不是它为什么会成功，但它有一种逻辑。我对其中蕴含的逻辑之多感到惊讶。那正是吸引我的地方。
And you can really see this logic on display in the congressional hearing about this idea. Back in 1910, testimony was heard for Broussard's bill, HR 23261, also known as the hippo bill. One of the main people called on to testify? Fred Burnham.
你可以真正地在国会关于这个想法的听证会上看到这种逻辑。早在1910年，就Broussard的法案（HR 23261，也称为河马法案）进行了证词听取。被叫去作证的主要人员之一？Fred Burnham。
Burnham did a really good job of making this sound normal. He made the point that, OK, what are the animals that Americans eat? Chickens, pigs, cows, sheep, lambs. None of those, really, are native to the US.
Burnham非常成功地让这一切听起来很正常。他指出，OK，美国人吃什么动物？鸡、猪、牛、羊、羔羊。这些中没有一个是美国原产的。
They were all brought centuries before by people from other parts of the world. But they had been here so long that we took them for granted as American cuisine. Really, the only thing that was native was turkeys. And we only ate that once a year.
它们都是几个世纪前由来自世界其他地区的人带进来的。但它们在这里存在太久了，我们认为它们是美国美食，视为理所当然。真正唯一本土的东西是火鸡。而我们一年只吃一次。
So why did we suddenly stop feeling free enough to change the landscape that way? And so the idea of solving the Meat Question this way, this is sort of where the beautiful poetry of it is. It was this key that unlocked all these other feelings of optimism and ambition and sort of stick-to-itiveness that America wanted to feel again. Because it was a way of saying, we have the smarts and the courage to solve this in a bold way.
所以为什么我们突然不再感到有自由去以那种方式改变景观了？所以以这种方式解决肉类问题的想法，这是它美丽诗意的地方。它是解锁所有这些对乐观主义、野心和毅力的其他感觉的钥匙，美国人想再次感受。因为它是一种说法，我们有聪明才智和勇气以一种大胆的方式解决这个问题。
What about, though, the other reaction, which is sort of like, yuck. That's disgusting. I'm not going to eat hippo meat. Yuck.
那另一种反应呢？比如，呕，真恶心。我不会吃河马肉的。呕。
Right. There was a lot of that. There was a kind of campaign to nudge people past that. You had this guy, WN Irwin, at the Department of Agriculture who was helping Burnham and Duquesne promote it. Apparently he had a supply of hippopotamus jerky that he offered to reporters here and there in his office.
对。那种反应很多。有一种推动人们超越这一点的运动。你在农业部有这位名叫WN Irwin的家伙，他在帮助Burnham和Duquesne推广它。显然他有一批河马肉干，他在办公室里到处送给记者。
And I found this story in the Washington Post. He had actually given it to a Washington Post reporter as he showed the Washington Post reporter a photo of that very hippo being skinned in Africa by a crowd of men. And that reporter liked it. "Toughness is only skin deep," is what he wrote.
我在《华盛顿邮报》找到了这个故事。他实际上把它给了《华盛顿邮报》的一名记者，同时向那位记者展示了一张那只河马在非洲被一群人剥皮的照片。那个记者喜欢它。“韧性只是表面的，”他写道。
So obviously, the state of Louisiana is not covered in hippo ranches. We don't have hippo bacon on the menus of fancy restaurants. So what happened? What got in the way of this vision?
所以显然，路易斯安那州并没有覆盖着河马牧场。我们高级餐厅的菜单上没有河马培根。所以发生了什么？是什么阻碍了这个愿景？
Yeah. That's a really good question. What got in the way of this vision? Frankly, a lot of the problem was administrative. They're all writing letters to each other all summer, all three men, trying to get this new food supply society up and running, which was going to be a lobbying firm to promote the idea in the next session of Congress. And I said to my editor on the story, I said, I'm starting to get the impression that if they had had email, this might have actually happened.
对。那是一个很好的问题。是什么阻碍了这个愿景？坦率地说，很大一部分问题是行政上的。他们整个夏天都在写信，这三个人，试图建立这个新的食物供应协会，这将是一个游说公司，在下一届国会会议上推动这个想法。我对我的故事编辑说，我说，我开始有种感觉，如果他们当时有电子邮件，这可能真的会发生。
It's just so infuriating. Duquesne writes to Broussard and says, what can I do for you? But Broussard is in South America. And then when he comes back, he gets the flu. And so you have back and forth with his secretary.
真令人恼火。Duquesne写信给Broussard说，我能为你做什么？但Broussard在南美。然后当他回来时，他得了流感。所以你不得不和他的秘书反复沟通。
Or Burnham is traveling in Mexico and can't be reached. Or someone misses a letter. They never got the letter. So then they write back two weeks later, I never received your reply to my last letter. So it got really messy and sloppy.
或者Burnham在墨西哥旅行，联系不上。或者有人漏了一封信。他们从来没收到信。所以两周后他们回信，我没收到你对上一封信的回复。所以它变得非常混乱和草率。
You tell this story at the very end of-- there's this scene at the very, very end of this piece that you wrote, where Frederick Burnham is now an older man. It's 1944.
你在结尾处讲了这个故事——你写的这篇文章结尾处有这样一个场景，Frederick Burnham现在是个老人了。那是1944年。
Yeah. 34 years after all this. At this point, he's a very distinguished man. He's become very wealthy. And he was preparing his papers for posterity at both Stanford and Yale. I guess that's how you know you've had an impressive life, when both Stanford and Yale libraries want your archives.
对。这一切发生34年后。此时，他是一位非常杰出的人。他变得非常富有。他正在为后代在斯坦福和耶鲁准备他的文件。我想这就是你如何知道你度过了令人印象深刻的一生，当斯坦福和耶鲁图书馆都想要你的档案时。
And he finds this speech that he had given to a civic organization in Pasadena in 1910. And he reads over the speech. And there he is in 1910, 34 years earlier, making the case to the general public of why this is going to work, why it's necessary, and just urging these laypeople to understand that what he calls the complacent belief in the unending plenty of our natural wealth was now so totally false. It was so obvious that wasn't true anymore.
他发现了他在1910年给帕萨迪纳一个公民组织演讲的演讲稿。他读了那次演讲。34年前的1910年，他就在那儿，向公众陈述为什么这会成功，为什么它是必要的，并敦促这些外行理解他所谓的对我们自然财富无尽充足的自满信念现在是多么完全错误。很明显那不再是真实的了。
But that here he was, humbly with this idea. He's assuring them. He's saying, the idea made sense. It makes sense. But it's going to require working against what he calls overwhelming difficulties and the loud guffaws of the ignorant to make it a reality.
但在这里，他谦卑地持有这个想法。他向他们保证。他说，这个想法有道理。它有道理。但这将需要克服他所谓的压倒性困难和无知者的喧闹嘲笑，才能使之成为现实。
And here he is, he reads this over. And still, he takes a pen and he writes in this very shaky, kind of old-man hand, he writes, "The facts are still unrefuted." And he signs it "FRB, 1944." And then he sends it off to the archives, which is where I found it.
他读了这些，仍然，他拿起一支笔，用那种非常颤抖的老人手，写道，“事实依然没有被驳倒。”并签上了“FRB，1944”。然后把它送到了档案室，我就是在那里找到它的。
Jon Mooallem talking to Alex Blumberg, who these days you may have heard on the StartUp podcast. You can read Jon's full account of the American hippopotamus, including everything about the crazy rivalry between Fred Burnham and Fritz Duquesne that we were not able to get into, at theativist.com. It's also available on amazon.com as an ebook.
Jon Mooallem与Alex Blumberg对话，你们最近可能在《StartUp》播客上听过他。你可以阅读Jon关于美国河马的完整记录，包括Fred Burnham和Fritz Duquesne之间我们无法涉及的所有疯狂竞争，在theativist.com。它也可以在amazon.com上作为电子书获取。
Act 4, Start Me Up. When comedian Tig Notaro was in sixth grade, she took this music class, and it was the kind of class where they would talk about Beethoven and The Who. And they would play instruments, and they read books. She described what happened in that class in front of a live audience at Largo in Los Angeles.
第四幕，启动我。当喜剧演员Tig Notaro上六年级时，她上了这门音乐课，那是那种他们会谈论贝多芬和The Who的课。他们会演奏乐器，读读本。她在洛杉矶Largo的现场观众面前描述了那门课上发生的事。
It was so much fun. I just-- I loved it. I was a huge Beatles and Rolling Stones fan. And at the end of every class, the teacher would let one kid play their favorite song for the whole class to hear. And I always brought in Beatles and Rolling Stones albums.
太有趣了。我只是——我爱死它了。我是披头士和滚石乐队的超级粉丝。每节课结束时，老师都会让一个孩子为全班播放他们最喜欢的歌。我总是带去披头士和滚石乐队的唱片。
And the coolest kid in our entire school, JD-- of course-- he came up to me after school one day, and he said, if I bring in my dad's Rolling Stones album, will you tell me a cool song to play? I said, absolutely. No doubt.
而且我们学校最酷的孩子JD——当然——有一天放学后走到我面前，说，如果我把我爸爸的滚石乐队唱片带来，你能告诉我不错的歌来放吗？我说，绝对。毫无疑问。
Next day, he brought in the Rolling Stones album Let it Bleed. I looked it over. I said, this song. Play this one. And I pointed at "You Can't Always Get What You Want."
第二天，他带了滚石乐队的唱片《Let it Bleed》。我看了看。我说，这首歌。放这首。我指着“You Can't Always Get What You Want”。
He said, are you sure? I was like, I couldn't be more positive. This is the coolest song that you could possibly play. And he was like, OK.
他说，你确定吗？我当时想，我不能再确定了。这是你所能放的最酷的歌。他当时说，OK。
So the teacher asked if anyone had a song. And JD raised his hand. She called him up to the front. He pointed out that song. And at that point, this is what the entire classroom heard.
所以老师问有没有人有歌。JD举了手。她叫他到前面去。他指出了那首歌。那时，这就是全班同学听到的。
[MUSIC - "YOU CAN'T ALWAYS GET WHAT YOU WANT" BY  THE ROLLING STONES]
[音乐 - 滚石乐队的“You Can't Always Get What You Want”]
JD was furious. He's looking at me like, what is this? And I'm like frantically signing, no, no, no, this is an amazing song. It gets better.
JD很愤怒。他看着我，像，这是什么？我像疯狂地打手势，不，不，不，这是一首很棒的歌。后面会更好听。
[MUSIC - "YOU CAN'T ALWAYS GET WHAT YOU WANT" BY  THE ROLLING STONES]
[音乐 - 滚石乐队的“You Can't Always Get What You Want”]
And then the bell rang. Nobody got to hear any more of that song. And the coolest kid in school just marched down there, grabbed his record, and turned to me and was like, thanks a lot, and then just bolted out of the classroom. I was like, no! It gets better! And I guess you can't always get what you want.
然后铃响了。没人能再听到那首歌的更多部分。学校里最酷的孩子径直走过去，抓起他的唱片，转身对着我说，谢了啊，然后就冲出了教室。我当时说，不！后面会更好听！我想你不能总是得到你想要的。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
Tig Notaro, her latest comedy albums and her podcast, Professor Blastoff , are at her website, tignation.com.
Tig Notaro，她最新的喜剧专辑和播客《Professor Blastoff》，在她的网站tignation.com。
[MUSIC - "YOU CAN'T ALWAYS GET WHAT YOU WANT" BY  THE ROLLING STONES]
[音乐 - 滚石乐队的“You Can't Always Get What You Want”]
Act 5, Happy Accident. Etgar Keret always had a good relationship with his dad, except for one thing. This story is true. It all happens in Israel, where Etgar lives, and was read for us in English translation by actor Michael Chernus.
第五幕，快乐的事故。Etgar Keret一直和他爸爸关系很好，除了那一件小事。这个故事是真的。它全都发生在以色列，Etgar住的地方，并由演员Michael Chernus为我们读了英文译本。
"30 years I'm a cabbie," the small guy sitting behind the wheel tells me. "30 years and not one accident." It's been almost an hour since I got into his taxi in Beersheba, and he hasn't stopped talking for a second.
“开出租车30年了，”坐在方向盘后面的小个子男人告诉我。“30年了，没发生过一次事故。”自从我坐上他在贝尔谢巴的出租车已经快一小时了，他一秒钟也没停止说话。
Under different circumstances, I would tell them him to shut up, but I don't have the energy for that today. Under different circumstances, I wouldn't shell out 350 shekels to take a taxi to Tel Aviv. I would take the train. But today I feel that I have to get home as early as I can.
换做不同情况，我会让他闭嘴，但今天我没精力那样做。换做不同情况，我不会花350谢克尔打车去特拉维夫。我会坐火车。但今天我觉得我必须尽快回家。
I spent last night at Ichilov Hospital with my wife. She had a miscarriage and was bleeding heavily. We thought it would be OK, till she passed out. It wasn't until we got to the emergency room that they told us that her life was in danger and gave her a blood transfusion.
昨晚我和妻子在Ichilov医院度过。她流产了，出血严重。我们以为会没事的，直到她晕过去。直到我们到了急诊室，他们才告诉我们她的生命有危险，并给她输了血。
Three days before that, my dad's doctors told me and my parents that the cancer at the base of his tongue, which had been in remission for four years, was back. And the tumor was at such an advanced stage that the only way to fight it was to remove his tongue and larynx. The oncologist said she didn't recommend having the surgery, but my dad said that he was for it.
在那之前三天，我爸爸的医生告诉我父母，他舌根部的癌症在缓解四年后复发了。肿瘤处于如此晚期，唯一抗击它的方法是切除他的舌头和喉头。肿瘤科医生说她不建议手术，但我爸爸说他赞成。
The oncologist told him that the operation would leave him seriously handicapped, unable to speak or eat. "At my age," my dad said, "all I need are my heart and my eyes so I can enjoy watching my grandchildren grow."
肿瘤科医生告诉他，手术会让他严重残疾，无法说话或进食。“到我这个年纪，”我爸爸说，“我所需要的只是我的心脏和眼睛，这样我才能享受看着孙子们长大。”
When we left the room, the doctor whispered to me, "Try to talk to him." She clearly doesn't know my dad.
当我们离开房间时，医生对我耳语，“试着和他谈谈。”她显然不了解我爸爸。
The taxi driver repeats, for the 100th time, that in 30 years, he hasn't had a single accident and that all of a sudden, five days ago, his car kissed the bumper of the car in front of him, traveling at 20 kilometers per hour. When they stopped and checked, he saw that except for a scratch on the left side of the bumper, the other car hadn't really been damaged at all. He offered the other driver 200 shekels on the spot. But the driver insisted that they exchange insurance information.
出租车司机第一百次重复说，在30年里，他没发生过一次事故，突然间，五天前，他的车以每小时20公里的速度吻上了前面车的保险杠。当他们停下检查时，他看到除了保险杠左侧的一道划痕，另一辆车根本没损坏。他当场提议赔偿对方200谢克尔。但对方坚持要交换保险信息。
The next day, the driver, a Russian, asked him to come to a garage. And he and the owner, probably a friend of his, showed him a huge dent all the way on the other side of the car and said the damage was 2,000 shekels. The cab driver refused to pay, and now the other guy's insurance company was suing him. "Don't worry, it'll be OK," I tell him, in the hope that my words will make him stop talking for a minute.
第二天，那名驾驶员，一个俄罗斯人，要求他去一家车库。他和老板，可能是他的朋友，给他看了车另一侧的一个大凹痕，说修理费是2000谢克尔。出租车司机拒绝支付，现在对方的保险公司正在起诉他。“别担心，会没事的，”我告诉他，希望我的话能让他停止说话一分钟。
"How will it be OK?" he complains. "They're going to screw me. Those bastards are going to squeeze the money out of me. You see how unfair it is? Five days I haven't slept. Do you get what I'm saying?"
“怎么会没事？”他抱怨道。“他们要坑我。那些混蛋会榨干我的钱。你看到这有多不公平了吗？五天了，我没睡过觉。你明白我在说什么吗？”
"Stop thinking about it," I suggest. "Try thinking about other things in your life, happy things."
“别想它了，”我建议。“试着想想你生活中的其他事情，快乐的事情。”
"I can't," the cab driver groans and grimaces. "I just can't."
“我不能，”出租车司机呻吟并皱着脸。“我就是不能。”
"Then stop talking to me about it," I say. "Keep on thinking and suffering, but just don't tell me about it anymore, OK?"
“那就别跟我谈它了，”我说。“继续想，继续受苦，但只是别再跟我说它了，OK？”
"It's not the money," the taxi driver continues, "believe me. Yesterday I went with my son to the graves of the Sadikim. We bought blessings for 1,800 shekels, and I didn't mind paying. It's the injustice that gets me."
“这不是钱的问题，”出租车司机继续说，“相信我。昨天我和我儿子去了Sadikim的坟墓。我们花了1800谢克尔买了祝福，我不介意支付。是那种不公正让我难受。”
"Shut up," I say, finally losing it. "Just shut up for a minute!"
“闭嘴，”我终于忍不住爆发了。“就闭嘴一分钟！”
"What are you yelling for?" the cab driver asks, insulted. "I'm an old man. It's not nice."
“你大叫什么？”出租车司机受到侮辱问道。“我是一个老人。这不礼貌。”
"I'm yelling because my father is going to die if they don't cut his tongue out of his mouth," I continue to yell. "I'm yelling because my wife is in the hospital after a miscarriage." The driver is silent for the first time since I got into his taxi. And now I'm suddenly the one who can't stop the stream of words.
“我大叫是因为如果他们不把他的舌头从他嘴里割出来，我父亲就会死，”我继续吼道。“我大叫是因为我妻子流产后在医院里。”司机自打我坐上他的出租车以来第一次保持沉默。而现在我突然变成了那个无法停止说话的人。
"Let's make a deal," I say. "Get me to an ATM, and I'll take out 2,000 shekels and give it to you. In exchange, it'll be your father who has to have his tongue removed and your wife who's lying in a hospital bed getting a blood transfusion after a miscarriage."
“做个交易吧，”我说。“把我送到取款机，我取出2000谢克尔给你。作为交换，变成必须割掉舌头的是你父亲，变成在流产后躺在医院病床上输血的是你妻子。”
The driver is still silent, and now so am I. I feel a little uncomfortable for having shouted at him but not uncomfortable enough to apologize. To avoid his eyes, I look out the window. We missed the exit to Tel Aviv. I tell him that politely-- or I shouted angrily, I don't recall anymore.
司机依然沉默，现在我也是。因为对他大吼大叫，我感到有点不安，但还没到道歉的程度。为了避开他的眼睛，我看着窗外。我们错过了去特拉维夫的出口。我礼貌地告诉他——或者我愤怒地大喊，我记不清了。
He tells me not to worry. He doesn't really know the way, but in a minute, he'll find out. A few seconds later, he parks in the right lane of the highway after managing to convince another driver to stop. He starts to get out of the taxi to ask for directions to Tel Aviv.
他让我别担心。他确实不知道路，但一分钟后，他就会找到。几秒钟后，他在高速公路右车道停车，在那之后设法劝服另一位司机停车。他开始下出租车问去特拉维夫的路。
"You'll kill us both," I tell him. "You can't stop here."
“你会害死我们俩的，”我告诉他。“你不能停在这儿。”
"30 years I'm a cabbie," he tosses back at me as he gets out of the taxi. "30 years and not one accident."
“开出租车30年了，”他下车时抛给我一句话。“30年了，没发生过一次事故。”
Alone in the cab, I can feel the tears rising. I don't want to cry. I don't want to feel sorry for myself. I want to be positive like my dad. My wife is fine now, and we already have a wonderful son. My dad survived the Holocaust.
独自在出租车里，我能感觉到泪水涌上。我不想哭。我不想为自己感到难过。我想像我爸爸一样积极。我的妻子现在没事了，我们已经有了一个很棒的儿子。我爸爸在纳粹大屠杀中幸存下来。
That's not just the half-full glass, it's an overflowing one. I don't want to cry, not in this taxi, not next to this driver that I yelled at. The tears are welling up and will soon begin to flow.
这不仅仅是半杯满的玻璃杯，它是一杯溢出的。我不想哭，不在这辆出租车里，不在这位被我吼叫的司机旁边。泪水正在涌出，很快就要流下来了。
Suddenly I hear a crashing boom and the sound of windows breaking. The world around me shatters. A silver car veers across the next lane, completely smashed.
突然，我听到一声碰撞声和窗户破碎的声音。我周围的世界碎了。一辆银色车越过下一条车道，完全粉碎。
The taxi moves too, but not on the ground. It floats above it, towards the concrete wall on the side of the road. After it hits, there's another bang. Another car must have hit the taxi.
出租车也移动了，但不在地面上。它漂浮在上面，冲向路边的水泥墙。在它撞击之后，又有一次碰撞。另一辆车一定撞上了出租车。
A second before the ambulance drives away, they load the taxi driver into it. Deep in my heart, I was hoping they'd send us in separate ambulances, but it just wasn't my day. The driver, looking revitalized and happy, lights a cigarette. The paramedic wears a yarmulke and tells me I was very lucky. An accident like that with no deaths is a miracle.
在救护车开走前一秒，他们把出租车司机装了进去。在我心底深处，我希望他们用不同的救护车送我们，但今天确实不是我的日子。司机，看起来恢复活力且快乐，点了一根烟。医护人员戴着小圆帽，告诉我我很幸运。那样没有死亡的事故是个奇迹。
"The minute you're discharged from the hospital," he says, "you should run to the nearest synagogue and give thanks for still being alive." My cellphone rings. It's my dad. He's only calling to ask how my day at the university was and whether the little one is asleep yet.
“你从医院出院的那一分钟，”他说，“你应该跑去最近的犹太教堂，感谢你还活着。”我的手机响了。是我爸爸。他打电话只是问我在大学的一天过得怎么样，那个小的睡着了没。
I tell him that the little one is sleeping and my day at the university was great. And Shira, my wife, is fine, too. She just stepped into the shower.
我告诉他小的正在睡觉，我在大学的一天很棒。Shira，我妻子，也没事。她刚走进淋浴间。
"What's that noise?" he asks.
“那是什么声音？”他问。
"An ambulance siren," I tell him. I try to sound casual. "One just passed by on the street."
“救护车警笛，”我告诉他。我试着听起来随意。“一辆刚从街上经过。”
Once, five years ago when I was in Sicily with my wife and son, I called my dad to ask how he was. He said everything was fine. In the background, a voice on a loudspeaker was calling a Dr. Shulman to the operating room.
曾经，五年前当我和妻子儿子在西西里岛时，我打电话问爸爸他怎么样。他说一切都好。背景里，扩音器里的声音正在呼叫Shulman医生去手术室。
"Where are you?" I asked.
“你在哪儿？”我问。
"In the supermarket," my dad said without a moment's hesitation. "They're announcing on the loudspeaker that someone lost her purse." He sounded so convincing when he said that, so confident and happy.
“在超市，”我爸爸毫不犹豫地说。“他们在扩音器里宣布有人丢了钱包。”他说这话时听起来那么令人信服，那么自信和快乐。
"Why are you crying?" my dad asks now from the other side of the line.
“你为什么在哭？”我爸爸现在在电话那头问。
I force myself to smile, hoping he can sense it, too. "It's nothing," I say as the ambulance stops next to the emergency ward and the paramedic slams the ambulance doors open. "Really, it's nothing."
我强迫自己微笑，希望他也能感觉到。“没什么，”我说，当救护车停在急诊室旁边，医护人员猛地打开救护车门时。“真的，没什么。”
Michael Chernus, reading a story by Etgar Keret. Etgar's most recent book is Suddenly a Knock on the Door.
Michael Chernus，朗读Etgar Keret的一个故事。Etgar最近的一本书是《突然一阵敲门声》。
[MUSIC - "HOW ARE YOU DOING" BY THE LIVING SISTERS"]
[音乐 - The Living Sisters的“How Are You Doing”]
Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help today from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddis.
好了，我们的节目今天由Miki Meek和我自己，以及Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sean Cole、Sarah Koenig、Jonathan Menjivar、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike制作。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。Simon Adler提供制作帮助。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的办公室经理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。Michelle Harris和Julie Beer提供今天的研究帮助。Damien Graef和Rob Geddis提供今天的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送至公共广播电台。